anyone great that you and I follow in
the world anybody they all had a
defining moment every single one of them
had a defining moment in a defining
moment is an opportunity you have to
rise up to the occasion that that
defines the rest of your career and
opportunities galore came from come from
everywhere
let me explain for Michael Jordan was in
college when he played for North
Carolina and he hit that shot that won
them the championship for Jordan then he
realized he can handle pressure in the
NBA but they always go back to the shot
he made in college for Barack Obama it
was a it was a talk he gave at the
Democratic National Convention which
many of you remember in Oh for Senator
Obama comes and gives a talk and they
said he sounds presidential he took
advantage of that defining moment for Al
Pacino it was an audition he did for
Godfather for Godfather he was a no-name
he was a nobody then he comes in boom he
becomes a guy he was not the guy at the
top of the list if you go research and
find out who is at the top of the list
Pacino wasn't even in top 100 of people
to play that role and look who he
becomes he becomes the Godfather in that
movie in soccer you can go to Maradona
with the hand of God when argentina beat
England which was a very you know
political thinkers of England Argentina
was a very very big thing we are going
to impact the world the history books
are saving a space a chapter or two for
what you and I are gonna do that's going
to define how the world is going to be
affected inspire to become entrepreneurs
and you don't even know that yet you
don't even know that yet this is why I
told you this is a defining moment in
your life financially business for you
to finally realize what is made up up in
here for you to realize you have all the
abilities to become the greatest version
of you you can be but you got to make
that decision I can't do it for you I
wish I was there to be able to touch
every single one you guys when I'm
talking to you right now sit right in
front you say hey look at me it's just
you and I this is it it's us just me and
you please believe this this doesn't
happen a hundred times in your life this
will only happen a couple times in your
life this is one of those
moments you'll be amiss the last one
don't miss this one
it ain't going to last forever don't
miss it that's us right now
you